No goes
animal abuse,
no animal abuse.
Respect animals,
please do not leave them tied to the sun,
to the water.
Our animals feel the same way we do
than our children,
is sacrilege,
it is a sin to mistreat them,
then join us
and be the voice of animals in their homes.
Help respect our animals.
We ask people who have their vehicle
to be careful on the roads,
they are totally innocent beings
who do not know how to pass the street.
We invite people
and roadway drivers
who have more responsibility in this regard.
You see a little animal,
please stop and allow him to pass on the road,
we cannot continue to be in these situations
where we are claiming a few women,
some men
that are accompanying us
by the voice of the animals
in this type of very delicate case
and remember that you are not invisible beings,
are part of us,
are God's creation.
We invite this community that today
put a stop to your way
and think more about these little animals
that do us so much good.
They change our lives and are beings of light.
and the idea is to accompany these colleagues
and call on the entire community to
because it is a lack of awareness.
Drivers also
to please respect the roads
the life of animals